I like could not find a lot of images on
it like at all
yeah um well
it's something yeah it's definitely
suppressed somewhat they'll probably on
social media they'll probably blur it
out or because I mean in YouTube we had
an abortion video up and they took it
down on YouTube but then we kind of said
well you know you say it's a medical
procedure so why can't we have medical
procedures on YouTube so they reinstated
it but covered it oh it was only if
you're subscribed and over 18. so yeah
it's definitely suppressed definitely
suppressed but you can see you know when
people see it they really do change
their minds and you know people can go
to abortionreality.com and see abortion
for themselves
when you say we roof sorry I know we've
never met before who do you represent or
work for or what is your I work for an
organization called CBR UK so the center
for bioethical reform UK is where human
rights organization and does that
represent like All Humans of course I've
never heard yeah we stand up for we
educate on the humanity of The Unborn
Child and the reality of abortion and we
support women who've been through it
yeah
I'm just like I keep thinking about the
kid that came out it was it was crazy
because I'm just shocked at like six
weeks like that's not far at all yeah
like when I Googled six weeks it didn't
see what it didn't show me what I
birthed basically
um you know what I think some of the
confusion with ages is that when you're
pregnant they use LMP which is your last
menstrual period yep so actually when
you conceive so say my last menstrual
period was you know mid-october
um that's not when you conceive because
you don't know when you've had sex and
stuff so actually the the baby is
normally conceived about two weeks after
if that makes sense so so a lot of the
the images that we use we date and your
baby was was would have been from
um conception yes you said you said six
or eight weeks yeah yeah Savannah yeah
they had everything yeah it had
everything yeah would I have done it if
I knew that no
no but but it's like but like again like
I'm I I'm for life right pro-life right
but at the same time like it's someone's
Choice it's like even coming out with
abortions and saying if someone wants to
kill someone on the street they can it's
their choice and that's sort of what I'm
saying right but it's still not legal
yeah it's not legal exactly yeah because
people need to be protected right yeah
do you do you guys
um think that women that get abortions
should be
um pursued to the fullest extent of the
law
what's up with me so if um for the
pro-life people here
I think we should uh prosecute the
doctors because at currently uh the as
we've heard from the panel the doctors
know full well what they're doing they
know it's a human being and they know
that they're what they're going to do to
that human being is going to kill it so
I think we should prosecute the doctors
and the abortion
um industry uh not the women because
most of the women are not fully informed
as we've already discussed okay
um
sorry you have to run that question by
me again um do you think that women if
um they were to Outlaw abortion do you
think women that get abortions should be
pursued to the fullest extent of the law
um
well that would put me in that category
wouldn't it but um I meant moving so
like if they if they pass a law tomorrow
they can't per like put someone in jail
from before the law was passed so it
would just be like women in the future
you know like if you change the speed
limit to 50 and it was 40 last week they
don't say you drove 45 last week
um I I
just think that you know
fat woman
doesn't have the full picture
so therefore
as it stands anyway so therefore
similar to what Ruth is saying
the the doctors that are signing off
these women to or permitting them to
have these abortions
um and those that are actively
performing the abortions should be held
to account now I'll just say something
very quickly from my own experience was
that
from my understanding there should have
been two signatures to permit my
abortion and there wasn't what was the
second one sorry so what signature they
normally you normally have two
signatures
um so one doctor would
um
sign and in other words
counter sign to authorize the abortions
yeah
so that wasn't the situation that I that
wasn't my own personal experience it was
very much
in the hospital consultation I mean that
I'm pregnant and the first thing that
was offered to me was an abortion
um I just feel like they
they should be other options given to
that woman
so yeah because you were 19. I was nice
and so that was the first thing yeah
okay yeah
um yeah so
you're very I can see it like still
affects you it does it does um so it's
just going back to what Cass said you
know you say you train your mind to
forget but like we're here today it's
it's part of my tapestry I can't forget
I could I've moved on with my life I
have been healed from my experience
but
I like most traumas you can't forget it
it's just you learn to cope and you
learn to forgive yourself for it that's
what people say right that's what
everyone says but the brain is capable
of everything the brain is like a
computer if you tell um like you know
you have to organize it in certain
folders if you don't want something on
the computer you can move it to the bin
folder and and people don't realize that
I've had a lot of things happen to me
and and most of the things I've actually
forgotten about until I actually come
and speak on these subjects and people
bring these subjects up I'm like oh yeah
that's happened to me oh oh yeah like
I'm really good with those things
um so what I would do is I would like if
the memory comes back again it's very
good to start off with for forgiveness
forgiving yourself for giving whatever
the doctors no signatures or all those
things yeah absolutely that's the first
step but the second step is working with
your brain your brain communicates to
you through your imagination therefore
you should respond with your imagination
so when that memory comes you can
imagine scrunching it putting into the
bin folder your brain will adapt your
brain will know it you are the engineer
of of that computer you are the engineer
of your life your brain thinks it can
control you only because you haven't
taken that power
but no one knows that you know everyone
just lets the brain do everything the
amount of thoughts that we get every day
and it could be so Random like random
thoughts that don't even belong to our
personality you know but but we can
control that we can and and things like
that's happened to us we don't need to
think about it we don't need to feel the
pain every time like it's happened to
you so long ago and I can feel it in
your chest in in your emotions it's
still there and it's still resurfacing
you know so if you just practice this
I'm scrunching up putting into the bin
folder
um trust me the brain will adapt quicker
than you think and eventually it will
stop showing up like the whole memory
will just disappear
um in my case I don't want it to
disappear only because I share my
experience with other women
um
so it allows them to understand that
there is hope there is healing so
although I'm emotive when I speak about
it it's not because I'm like holding on
or dwelling to it dwelling yeah on it
it's because I
allow myself and I told myself that
because of what I experienced and
because I wasn't well informed and
because I knew how long it took me to
heal the trauma that I had from it I
want to be able to share my experience
with other people so I do share it on a
lot of platforms anyway I mean yeah like
I share my experiences as well right but
it's like that memory really just
disappears and it's only when I want it
to return it returns it's like the brain
doesn't just give it to me like it used
to no not over daily Bible you know they
walk around daily thinking oh gosh I had
an abortion as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible